in your job and in your life as an
emergency room physician you see that
life is so precious and you've probably
seen people that unfortunately haven't
made it and some that have and you see
their families how do you apply this
statement of life and you set it to your
life I mean do your own life I don't
know if I'm saying this right how do you
how does the statement life apply to
what you put into your work and some of
the subjects that you tackle because I
know you said that you don't want to
necessarily always do a documentary
about things are very powerful too you'd
rather show a story a narrative because
you feel that people can accept it in a
different way if they see it portrayed
with actors or maybe I'm inserting
Sherwood's life is the most precious
thing there is on this planet period you
know so and it's also limited we all
know that we know there's a beginning
and there's an end so during the
duration it is important for me because
like you said Karen I have seen the
extremes of life and death situations
you know every day while in my practice
that when it comes to the creative field
I need to not only first of all engage
people's minds and hearts because if I'm
if I am taking their time for an hour or
for two hours in a film and having them
sit and watch I need to keep their mind
completely engaged so in my experience
through my years have seen that fiction
seems to pull in more audiences than
documentaries do at least in my
experience so that is where my concept
of creating in including me if I had the
option of watching a very acclaimed
fictional narrative film versus a
documentary and I had that two hours
time I would naturally gravitate to the
fictional film first because I that is
how
our brains are kind of wired to work
unless you are a documentary filmmaker
unless you are in that niche of you know
just that is your passion only then but
I want to hit the entire worlds audience
you know with my films so but i also
want to deliver awareness I want to
deliver hope with my films and and I
want to deliver entertainment because if
they are going to come there and sit
there I don't want them walking out
feeling heavier and sadder and more
bogged down than they did when they
walked in you know so how do i do all of
that together that's how I decided to
make films where I sit with my team and
I i create a very entertaining story
line with drama with romance with
emotions with dance with music which is
of course my childhood base you know and
also the fact that from india the talent
is outstanding i mean i can say this
without doubt that they are the artistic
talent that comes from india is the best
in the world only thing is it may not be
the most exposed in the world because
they don't all do not have platforms you
know there are in villages in cities in
small towns you see children with the
sense of rhythm of precision of
discipline of body control you know all
that in dance music chanting learning
which is to me boggles my mind and do
you think all of them I can ever put it
out into the world to show that talent
they are not able to so in my minimal
way that was another thing that I was
thinking of I was thinking okay if I can
create a medium and that to cinema being
one of the most prolific mediums out
there which reaches a whole world if I
can create a medium where I have the
entertaining story line where I have
incredible music and dance and and which
is also becoming very popular in the
West people are loving the whole
the Bollywood feel the Indian feel of
you know the colors the vibrance on all
of that and bring in very important
public awareness messages in there and
put it somehow that it hits with an
impact and people love it when they love
it they're going to go tell other people
and they go to come and watch so that
was my goal so with my first film which
was Joe Joe Lolley a heart-wrenching
lullaby we created a very small budget
experiment it was a 40 minute film on
hiv/aids awareness and we made it about
the vertical transmission of HIV from
mother to child which is very much it's
not it's the people are aware but it is
not much spoken about not much known so
we took that subject and meet the story
and it was a brilliant success you know
in it won 13 Awards an Indian film
festivals and then it was played in
Dubai and Brazil and across the US in
Atlanta in Boston and the pediatric AIDS
conferences in all of these places and
we had a Tucson premiere recently so
it's just marching across you know it's
still marching it's four and a half
years old but it's still marching across
people asking for it wanting screenings
and they come out crying and it's not
tears of oh I had the most boring time
of my life or I'd bog me down it was
that inspired thing of saying we need to
do something we need to help this cause
we need to take this film everywhere and
we loved it you know so that first
experiment made me feel okay I'm in the
right path you know I'm doing something
correctly so that's how the first one
came about and from there we are moving
on you know that I can speak all day
about the next film and the next film
but
you